الى العراق حيث قالت المديريه العامه
للمرور ان عدد المركبات الموجود في بغداد
يفوق الطاقه الاستيعابيه لشوارع العاصمه
بنحوي 10 اضعاف واوضح مدير اعلام وعلاقات
المديريه العميد زياد القيسي ان الشوارع
لا تستوعب الكمه الهائله من المركبات
مشيرا الى احصائيه وزاره التخطيط بان
الشوارع تستوعب من 200 الى 250,000 مركبه
كحد اقصى وكانت السلطات العراقيه قد عملت
مؤخرانيه الى فتح العديد من الطرق المغلقه
ورفع عدد اخر من نقاط التفتيش بالاضافه
الى فتح المنطقه الخضراء في خطوه للتخفيف
من الزخم المريضي في العاصمه بغداد
[موسيقى]
من بغداد ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره سامر
يوسف سامر مديريه المرور العامه تقول ان
عدد المركبات في بغداد يفوق الطاقه
الاستيعابيه بنحو عشره اضعاف فما الذي يتم
فعله لحل هذه المشكله
[موسيقى]
بالفعل عثمان الطاقه الاستيعابيه كما
اسلفت من 200,000 الى 250,000 مركبه في
شوارع بغداد الطاقه الموجوده الان في
شوارع بغداد عدد المركبات يتجاوز ثلاثه
ملايين مركبه نحن نقف الان في وسط احدى
الساحات في العاصمه العراقيه همم بغداد
هكذا يبدو اا المشهد على الرغم من ان همم
الساعه الان منتصف النهار لا تبدو ساعه
ذروه همم انما ساعات الدروع بعد ان تخرج
دوائر الدوله والموظفين الى
بيوتها بعد الساعه الثانيه بحسب التوقيت
المحلي لهذا الشهر الذي واضح همم امام همم
عثمان طوله بحوالي همم كيلو مترين نحن نقف
في بدايه هذا الشارع وهذا الازدحام يمتد
الى همم نهايته همم همم
السلطات هنا همم بالفعل عمدت الى فتح طرق
عده من بغداد شوارع العاصمه ولكن ما زالت
هذه الاختناقات المروريه تغطي همم شوارع
بغداد لان هذه الشوارع وفعليا لم تشهد همم
اي توسعه حقيقيه او اي شبكه طرق همم جديده
همم
يعني ملموسه على ارض الواقع وبشكل همم
يستوعب هذه هي الطاقه منذ عام 2003 بعض
التعديلات البسيطه التي يمكن ملاحظتها همم
عثمان اتحدث مع احد همم المواطنين هنا
الذي فضل استخدامين بدلا من همم السياره
ما طبيعه هذه الازدحامات هل هي يوميه
وصعبه يعني كل صعبه يعني اللي كثرت
السيارات السيارات الازدحامات الشوارع
محدوده الجسور متكفي اللي عنده دوام قاعد
يتعطلبات المدارس طلبت الكليات يعني
لها علاج يعني اقوى افضل يعني شكرا لك احد
المواطنين هنا همم
يعيش هذه الاختناقات المروريه
كم يحتاج العراق الى الاختناقات المرو
ريه
انفاق
تحتاج لقطع شارع من كيلو مترين مثلا في
وسط الازدحامات
عثمان همم بعض السلطات تقترح بعض
التعديلات في شوارع بغداد مثل التوسعه
حدثت هذه التوسعه في بعض الساحات همم
بغداد همم تكبير الشوارع هناك ولكن ما
زالت الطاقه الاستيعابيه كبيره جدا في
شوارع بغداد وخصوصا حتى في مداخل العاصمه
شكرا جزيلا لك من بغداد الجزيره سامر يوسف